Sur l'île de Bangka,
les forêts cachent des paysages dévastés.
Ici, une trentaine d'hectares a été rasée
afin d'exploiter un gisement d'étain.
Sur cette plaine où
plus rien ne poussera jamais,
les sols ont été
terrassés et inondés,
transformés en
un vaste étang boueux.
Par 40 degrés, une vingtaine
de mineurs creusent sans relâche.
Leur technique
d'extraction s'appelle radjouk.
À l'aide d'une tige de forage,
ils transpercent le sous-sol
à huit mètres de profondeur.
Nous avons tous la même
technique pour extraire l'étain.
Parfois, elle est compliquée
à mettre en œuvre.
Le sol est dur et le forage
prend plus de temps.
Cela arrive que la corde
qui sert à remonter la tige se casse
ou que le tuyau qui pompe
le sable se coince au fond de l'eau.
Il faut alors plonger,
mais sinon,
lorsque tout fonctionne,
le travail est facile.
Au milieu des visages sales
des autres mineurs, Ikrane, 13 ans.
Il travaille ici neuf heures
par jour, six jours sur sept.
Il a abandonné l'école, il y a deux ans
pour devenir mineur comme son père.
C'est moi qui ai
décidé de quitter l'école,
personne ne m'a forcé.
Être mineur,
c'est difficile au début.
Il y a des accidents
et on se fait souvent mal,
mais maintenant,
ça va, je me suis habitué.
La plupart des enfants mineurs
de Bangka travaillent avec leurs parents,
parfois sur les forages,
le plus souvent au nettoyage du sable.
Ikrane sait le pétrir
à la manière des chercheurs d'or,
son père lui a appris les gestes.
Il les répète inlassablement,
jusqu'à faire apparaître
cette pâte noire lourde et compacte.
C'est de la cassitérite,
le minerai d'étain.
À le voir remplir son sac à ras bord,
on devine son excitation
à peser son pactole.
Elle a lieu sous la surveillance
de la propriétaire du terrain.
Elle ne détient
aucun permis d'extraction,
mais elle autorise
les mineurs à l'exploiter
à condition qu'ils lui reversent
dix pourcent de leur butin.
Ikrane et son père ont extrait
ce jour-là 60 kilos de minerais.
À la revente, ils pourront
gagner dans les 300 euros,
un mois de salaire moyen en Indonésie.
Une fortune qui
explique pourquoi sur l'île,
tous sont gagnés
par la fièvre de l'étain.
Un Eldorado,
voilà de quoi rêvent
les 100 000 mineurs de Bangka.
La plupart sont venus des quatre coins
de l'archipel pour exploiter le filon.
Située sur la Tin Belt,
une zone d'Asie du Sud-est
qui concentre les plus
grands gisements de la planète.
L'île fournit l'essentiel
de la production du pays,
80 000 tonnes en
sont extraites chaque année,
destinées aux géants
de l'informatique et de la téléphonie.
Plusieurs compagnies
minières se partagent le marché.
Parmi elles, PT Timah,
le plus gros producteur de l'île.
Dans mon portable, il y a forcément
de l'étain provenant de Bangka ?
Oui, en effet.
L'étain de Bangka est
vendu dans le monde entier ?
Je suppose, oui.
L'Indonésie produit plus
d'un quart de la production mondiale.
La moitié de la production vient de Chine,
mais les Chinois consomme leur étain
sur leur marché intérieur,
ils n'exportent pas.
En dehors de la Chine,
50 pourcent de la consommation
mondiale d'étain provient d'Indonésie.
À ce jour, 1 075 concessions
minières sont enregistrées sur l'île,
mais il en existerait
des milliers d'autres
exploités de façon illégale,
échappant à tout contrôle des autorités.
Comme ici à Muntok,
dans cette ancienne carrière abandonnée,
une cinquantaine de mineurs
pillent les dernières ressources.
Il suffit de creuser toujours plus
profond pour récolter quelques kilos.
Chaque jour, Sofiane,
33 ans, descend dans son trou
à 15 mètres de profondeur.
Il y travaille sans protection,
à la merci des glissements de terrain.
On n'a pas les moyens
d'utiliser des machines
pour terrasser la mine
alors nous nous servons de pioches.
C'est plus dangereux
car les étais sont moins solides,
il peut y avoir des éboulements
et on essaie d'être prudents.
Un jour, la paroi
d'une mine s'est effondrée
et j'ai dû fuir rapidement.
L'appât du gain leur
fait prendre tous les risques.
Aucune statistique officielle
ne comptabilise le nombre d'accidents,
mais ils seraient entre 100
et 150 à perdre la vie chaque année.
Comme ici, près de
la capitale Pangkal Pinang,
des pluies diluviennes
n'ont laissé aucune chance
à quatre mineurs ensevelis vivants.
Malgré le danger, Sofiane
n'a pas l'intention de changer de métier.
Il souhaite même
investir dans une pelleteuse
pour accroître ses rendements.
Avant, je travaillais
comme chauffeur routier,
je transportais du poisson.
Tous savent que les mines
rapportent beaucoup d'argent
alors j'ai changé de métier.
Avec deux associés, on a tout
de suite trouvé de l'étain en quantité
et mes revenus ont augmenté.
En tant que chauffeur,
je touchais 200 000 rupiahs par jour.
Aujourd'hui, je peux
gagner jusqu'à cinq fois plus.
À la tombée de la nuit,
la cassitérite extraite illégalement
s'échange à l'abri des regards.
Alfonso est négociant, chaque soir,
il reçoit chez lui entre 20 et 30 clients.
Les mineurs viennent
chez moi pour peser leur étain
et je fixe un prix d'achat
qui dépend du poids et de la qualité.
Je regarde surtout le pourcentage
d'étain contenu dans le minerai.
Je vérifie aussi
qu'il n'y a pas d'autres métaux.
Alfonso paye cash
entre quatre et six euros du kilo.
Chaque mois, il en
achète près de deux tonnes.
La cassitérite est ensuite
revendue à des grossistes
puis à des fonderies qui la
transformeront en lingots d'étain.
Pour limiter la contrebande,
la compagnie PT Timah
est la seule depuis 2016
à pouvoir les stocker et les exporter.
Le marché est florissant depuis
un an et la pandémie de Covid 19,
le cours de l'étain a flambé
à plus de 22 000 dollars la tonne.
Des experts en géologie
ont réalisé pour nous
des études du sous-sol de Bangka
et d'après leurs résultats,
les stocks d'étain s'élèveraient
à plus d'un million de tonnes.
Nous avons commencé
à prospecter de nouveaux sites,
à creuser la roche primaire
avec des procédés d'extraction différents.
À mon avis, dans plus
de 50 ans, nous serons toujours là.
Nous continuerons
d'exploiter des gisements
et nous continuerons
d'en trouver d'autres.
Une catastrophe écologique
et des séquelles irréversibles.
L'ONG Walhi Les Amis de la Terre
dénonce depuis
plusieurs années ces ravages.
Selon elle, les mines
occuperaient les trois-quarts
de la superficie de l'île,
soit 600 000 hectares,
65 pourcent des forêts
auraient été rayés de la carte.
Pour son directeur, Jessic Amundian,
les autorités doivent
prendre des mesures fortes
pour sauvegarder ce
qu'il reste de l'environnement.
Nous demandons au
gouvernement régional et central
d'appliquer immédiatement
un moratoire sur les activités minières.
Ce moratoire doit être accompagné
d'un audit environnemental
afin que nous puissions dresser
un état des lieux de la situation.
Cet audit permettra, à terme,
de nous assurer des efforts
déployés pour protéger l'environnement.
L'entreprise PT Timah s'est engagée
dans une politique de reboisement
de ses anciennes mines.
Une reforestation souvent réduite
à néant par de nouveaux pilleurs.
C'est de notre
responsabilité de replanter.
Lorsque nos concessions
arrivent à expiration,
nous devons les reboiser.
Nous avons mis en place,
il y a cinq ans
un plan de reforestation
que nous avons mené à bien.
Nous avons décidé de renouveler
ce plan pour les cinq prochaines années.
À raison de 500 hectares par an,
nous allons replanter
2 500 hectares de terre.
D'après les données qu'on a
récupérées auprès de la compagnie minière,
200 hectares de terre
seulement ont été reboisés.
Elle continue pourtant de dire
que son plan de
réhabilitation a été un succès.
En réalité, l'environnement
est dans un état pitoyable,
l'industrie minière est
en train de détruire Bangka.
Rien ne semble pouvoir
arrêter cette ruée vers l'étain,
pas même l'appauvrissement
de la ressource.
Le rythme effréné des forages
a fini par épuiser les gisements.
Alors, les compagnies
minières et les mineurs illégaux
sont allés prospecter
le long des côtes.
En mer de Java,
les filons sont si prometteurs
que 60 pourcent de l'étain proviennent
aujourd'hui de mines sous-marines.
L'un des plus importants gisements
a été découvert à Batu Buyong.
Ici, la zone est si riche en minerais
qu'elle a été baptisée
la plage aux 1 000 radeaux.
Conséquence du pompage
du sable à grande profondeur,
la mer est boueuse, totalement trouble,
recouvrant les rivages
de glaise et de limon.
Ici, on trouve de la boue au fond de l'eau
et qui arrive directement sur la plage.
En une heure de forage,
ces radeaux peuvent générer
une sédimentation de près
de 200 mètres cubes de sable
qui stagnent ensuite
partout dans la mer.
Mineur depuis trois ans,
Atchane ne se préoccupe
guère de la pollution qu'il génère,
pourvu qu'il extrait
ses dix kilos quotidiens.
La boue est le premier moyen
de subsistance pour gagner sa vie ici.
J'aurais pu être pêcheur,
mais je n'avais pas assez d'argent.
Il en fallait pour acheter un gros
bateau et espérer des bons revenus.
C'est pour cela que
j'ai décidé de devenir mineur.
Au moins l'investissement
matériel est faible
et je peux bien gagner ma vie.
Chaque jour sur les plages,
c'est le même ballet.
Des centaines de tonnes
de cassitérite sont déchargées de barges
qui font la navette
avec des bateaux creusant au large.
Comme le KIP 11, une usine
flottante de 80 mètres de long.
Elle fait partie d'une flotte
de 53 navires appartenant à PT Timah.
Aux commandes, le capitaine Mishanto.
Il coordonne ce jour-là
une opération d'extraction
à 32 mètres de profondeur,
objectif 600 kilos
de cassitérite à remonter.
Pour extraire l'étain,
nous utilisons une tête foreuse
placée au bout d'une tige
qui broie le sous-sol marin.
Une fois que
les matériaux ont été concassés,
une pompe aspire le mélange
de sable, d'eau et de roche
et l'envoie sur le pont
où il sera tamisé.
Cette campagne de
forage va durer dix jours,
sans interruption, 24 h sur 24.
D'autres navires
prendront ensuite la relève
et exploiteront le gisement
jusqu'à son épuisement.
Nous nous apprêtions
à filmer sur le pont arrière
les tonnes de boues rejetées à la mer,
l'attachée de presse de la compagnie
nous demande d'arrêter notre caméra.
Nous interrogeons
alors le capitaine Mishanto
sur les conséquences
de ce forage sur l'environnement.
Il est visiblement embarrassé.
C'est de nouveau
l'attachée de presse qui intervient.
Il ne peut pas vous
répondre, je suis désolée.
Ce n'est pas son rôle
de vous expliquer cela.
Il peut juste vous parler de l'opération,
mais pas de l'impact sur l'écosystème.
La sédimentation est en train de polluer
tout l'écosystème marin de Bangka.
Le sable recouvre tout,
il étouffe le corail
et finit par tuer les récifs.
La conséquence, c'est que
les poissons qui s'y réfugient
sont obligés de changer d'habitat
et de se déplacer plus loin au large.
Le problème est grave
surtout pour les pêcheurs
travaillant dans ces
zones exploitées par les mines.
Les pêcheurs vivent
mal cette cohabitation forcée,
à l'origine, selon eux,
d'une baisse de la ressource halieutique.
Il y a quelques mois,
le village de Matras
a été l'épicentre d'une fronde
menée contre les mineurs.
À sa tête, Yamane Black,
membre du mouvement
de protection des pêcheurs.
Il a manifesté plusieurs fois
pour réclamer l'arrêt des mines
et la protection du littoral.
Il y va, selon lui, de la survie
des 45 000 pêcheurs de Bangka.
Nous nous battrons le temps qu'il
faudra pour que le gouvernement agisse.
Nous continuerons à protester
devant le palais
du gouverneur de la province.
On lui a demandé de
mettre fin aux mines illégales
au large de la plage de Matras.
On se sent délaissé dans notre combat.
Les autorités ont été très lentes
à aider les pêcheurs locaux.
Jusqu'à présent, on n'a pas
pensé à changer notre mode de vie.
Je continuerai d'aller en mer,
car la ressource en
poisson ne s'épuisera jamais.
Contrairement à l'exploitation
minière qui n'est pas durable.
Pour que tout devienne comme avant,
il faut que les mines disparaissent,
il faut vraiment qu'elles disparaissent.
Les pêcheurs de
Bangka ont le vague à l'âme.
Dharma, 56 ans,
a connu les pêches miraculeuses
puis peu à peu,
les pêches désastreuses.
Ce matin,
s'il veut prendre du poisson,
il doit jeter ses lignes
au-delà des zones de forage.
Avant les débuts
de l'exploitation minière,
un pêcheur pouvait
espérer de bons revenus.
Ils ont depuis vraiment diminué.
On attrapait du poisson et des calamars.
Aujourd'hui, c'est de plus
en plus difficile d'en pêcher.
Vous voyez, depuis
qu'on est arrivé, je n'ai rien pris.
Pourtant, habituellement,
la zone est riche en macro.
Est-ce que je pourrais changer de métier ?
Oui, mais je n'ai pas
d'autres compétences.
Je ne sais rien faire
d'autre à part pêcher.
Même si l'activité minière
n'était pas complètement arrêtée,
mais au moins réduite.
Il y aurait une chance
que la mer retrouve son état normal
et si les conditions ne changent pas,
nous n'attraperons plus rien
et nous devrons tout arrêter.
Il n'y aura pas d'espoir.
Dharma n'a pas fini de croiser
ses embarcations de malheur.
Attirés par de plus gros profits,
de plus en plus de pêcheurs
décident de devenir mineurs.
Ils ont transformé leurs bateaux
et naviguent en grappes,
arrimés les uns aux autres.
Cela leur permet d'explorer
le gisement sur une plus grande surface.
À bord, l'odeur du fuel
des moteurs vous prend à la gorge.
Sur les ponts,
plus de filets ni de nasses,
mais des rampes de lavage.
Ici, la technique
d'extraction est différente.
Chaque équipage a son plongeur,
respirant à l'aide d'un tuyau
d'arrosage fixé dans son masque.
Il pompe le sable au fond
de l'eau à 12 mètres de profondeur.
Après une plongée de deux heures,
Abderrahmane, 34 ans,
remonte complètement étourdi.
Mineur, plongeur depuis six ans,
il risque sa vie à chaque descente.
Sans expérience en tant que plongeur,
cela peut être vraiment dangereux.
Il y a souvent des victimes
ensevelies sous le sable.
Un jour, nous étions
plusieurs à creuser sous l'eau,
il y a eu un affaissement.
Un de mes amis s'est
retrouvé enterré, pris au piège.
Nous sommes descendus
à trois pour le sortir de là.
Nous avons réussi à le tirer,
mais il était déjà mort.
Bien sûr que j'ai peur quand je plonge.
Je dis toujours une prière
avant de commencer à travailler.
Quand je remonte, je remercie
aussi Dieu de m'avoir gardé en vie.
À l'écart des mines et des forages,
quelques sites sont
encore préservés de la pollution.
Dans l'Est de l'île,
les plages de Tanjung Pesona
offrent un décor
de carte postale prisé des touristes.
Ten Joannès est directeur
d'un complexe hôtelier
niché dans une nature luxuriante.
Son établissement compte
50 chambres et plusieurs villas privées.
Un environnement menacé, selon lui,
par l'arrivée de
bateaux le long de la côte.
Nous sommes ici
sur la plage de l'hôtel.
Vous voyez, le sable
et la mer sont propres.
On peut voir qu'il y a
beaucoup de bateaux à l'horizon.
Ces bateaux font
de l'extraction d'étain.
Cela m'inquiète parce qu'un
client est venu se plaindre
car la mer est polluée.
Ce n'est pas bon
qu'il y ait du carburant dans l'eau.
Cela ne donne vraiment pas
envie à nos clients d'aller nager.
Depuis plusieurs mois,
il observe une baisse de fréquentation.
Sa clientèle indonésienne
et australienne se fait plus rare.
Un manque à gagner important,
préjudiciable à son activité.
Voici une de nos suites
que nous réservons à nos clients
venant à Tanjung Pesona.
Ils sont souvent impressionnés
par la chambre et par la plage.
Malheureusement, cette
impression est gâchée à cause
des nombreuses mines d'étain illégales.
On nous cause
du tort à mes clients et moi.
À force, on ne pourra bientôt
plus travailler et on le regrettera tous.
Dans le nord de l'île, la baie de Kelabat
abrite plusieurs îlots paradisiaques
comme Pulau Putri,
l'île princesse en indonésien.
Il y a quelques mois encore,
elle était cernée de radeaux
et de bateaux forant les fonds marins.
Membre de l'ONG Kompala,
Arid Darmane Silla,
n'a pas hésité à défendre
ses eaux turquoise contre les mineurs.
Les membres de Kompala
sont très actifs à Bangka
et nous essayons d'avoir
une approche amicale avec les mineurs.
On est allé les voir
pour leur faire comprendre
que leur activité
minière n'est pas autorisée
car elle nuit à l'écosystème de l'île.
En plongeant ici, nous avons
constaté que les récifs de corail
étaient recouverts de boue.
Cependant, nous n'avons
pas porté de jugement hâtif
sur l'origine
de cette sédimentation.
Nous avons donc mené des études
pour vérifier l'état de l'estuaire.
Jusqu'à présent, il était propre.
Nous sommes montés
à bord de radeau d'extraction
pour prélever les boues rejetées
à la mer et qui dérivent avec le courant.
On les a analysées
et on les a comparées avec
les sédiments trouvés sur le corail.
On a pu en conclure
que c'étaient les mêmes
et que la pollution
provenait de l'activité minière.
Arid Darmane Silla
s'est lancé dans une
vaste opération de sauvetage.
Repiquer dans la baie plus
d'une centaine de plants de corail.
Nous comprenons
que les habitants de Bangka
veuillent gagner
leur vie grâce aux mines.
Nous espérons que
le gouvernement fera baisser
le nombre de concessions accordées.
Il doit créer des zones
réservées à l'extraction
et des zones naturelles protégées.
Il doit aussi créer suffisamment
d'emplois en dehors de l'activité minière
sinon cela ne s'arrêtera jamais.
Le gouvernement doit s'impliquer
dans la préservation de l'environnement.
Nous n'avons pas hérité de cette île,
nous l'empruntons et nous devons
la transmettre aux générations futures.
Le combat pour sauver
Bangka est loin d'être gagné.
L'île dépend largement
de l'industrie minière,
60 % de son économie
reposent sur l'exploitation de l'étain.
Ni la pêche ni l'agriculture
intensive ne pourront compenser
la perte d'une telle manne financière.
Les mineurs continueront donc de creuser
jusqu'à ce que Bangka
devienne à jamais un paradis perdu.